this video is made possible by nord VPN
get the nord VPN holiday deal at nord
VPN calm or would slash biographic sore
use coupon code buyer graphics
get a three year plan with 81% off plus
two amazing gifts for extra months plus
more pass password manager with a
hundred and ninety four dollars and 61
cents and let's get into it thanks to
the 1995 Mel Gibson movie Braveheart
most people are fairly familiar with the
name william wallace unfortunately
thanks to the same film most people have
a mental picture of him that varies
between marley and Acuras and completely
wrong but he was of course one of
Scotland's most iconic freedom fighters
right well the truth is fairly difficult
to track down in large part due to the
fact that he lived in the 13th century
records back then were if the app best
and doing even just a little bit of
digging uncovers the fact that some of
the original sources for many of the
well-known facts about Wallace's life
were viewed as dodgy right from the
beginning Wallis exists in that strange
realm somewhere between historical facts
and oft old legend which means
separating facts from fiction can be
tricky at best we're going to give it a
try though so stay tuned
[Music]
in order to truly understand Wallace and
why he became such a figurehead for
Scotland's national identity it's
important to know a little bit about the
world that he lived in and this all
starts with Alexander the 3rd Alexander
the third ruled Scotland from twelve
forty nine to twelve eighty-six after
being crowned King just eight years old
that sounds like a recipe for disaster
anything he was while he was still a
child rival factions within the country
struggled for control of the young king
but when he turned 21 he made it clear
that the crown was very much his own to
do with what he pleased and one of the
first things he did was to finish what
his father had started the islands off
the coast of his country were under
Norwegian control within just a few
years he had done what his father could
not he got those Islands back under
Scottish control meanwhile at home he
ushered in something of a golden age for
his nation trade flourished and
Scotland's was on good terms not only
with the countries and rulers of the
continents but with England to the land
dedicated agriculture continued to
sprawl monasteries and Abbey's popped up
across the country and these centres of
religious learning they flourished life
was for the most part surprisingly
peaceful but like most good things that
wasn't gonna last
Alexander first married Margaret and
tragically she and their two sons were
dead by 1283 they had a daughter - who
married Norway's King Erik per second
and had a daughter of her own that child
Margaret's the maid of Norway was
acknowledged as the heir to the throne
but things often don't go as planned the
king still wanted a male heir and ended
up remarrying he and Yolanda de Drew
comtesse de more for tied the knots in
1285 and for a time it looked as though
a male heir was a possibility Yolanda
was pregnant with their first child when
Alexander decided to ride from Edinburgh
to her side King on Castle he would
never finish the journey and a single
misstep by his horse changed history it
was dark the weather was terrible and
his horse slipped along the cliffside
Road near petechiae Alexander fell and
his body was recovered the following day
Yolanda would ultimately lose their only
child leaving the little maid of Norway
as the heir to the Scottish throne six
Guardians were appointed to watch over
Margaret who was just eight years old
Scotland
turns to the English monarchy to help
secure a position
as the new ruler ins England agreed the
King Edward the first drew up a treaty
which not only betrothed the little
Margaret's to his own son who would
later become Edward the second but also
guaranteed Scottish independence in 1290
Margaret the maid of Norway left Bergen
and headed to the aptly named st.
Margaret's Hope in South Ronald say and
there she died she passed away after
suffering from severe seasickness and
this is where the tale turns had
Margaret where'd Edward the second
Scotland and England would have been
United peacefully instead Scotland was
left with no immediate ruler and now
England's had a claim
now historians pretty much agree that
everything we just talked about actually
happened like we set but when it comes
to Wallis things are a little bit murky
he had already been born by the time
Scotland was plunged into the kind of
chaos that only comes when an entire
nation is left without a clear plan for
succession but there's no consensus on
even the basics like when and where he
was born
the closest historians have been able to
get is somewhere around twelve seventy
with both eldest Lee and Ellis Lee
laying claim to the honor of being his
birthplace
while Wallis definitely wasn't a
nobleman he wasn't exactly a peasant
either his father was a knight and minor
landowner and interestingly he likely
was from a family of fairly recent
immigrants to Scotland his family name
Wallace comes from Lowell a which means
the Welshman and it's thought that he
was a descendant of Richard Wallace who
had moved to Scotland alongside the
stewards only in the 12th century so
what else do we know about his early
years well not much he was well educated
knowing both French and Latin and that
was likely thanks to tutelage from his
uncle who was a priest at Dona base
given his later successes on the
battlefield historians have surmised
that he had military experience before
his rise as a revolutionary and it's
even been suggested that he fought for
Edward the first in various Welsh
campaigns it's also thought the Wallis
had run-ins with the law well before he
answered the call of the revolutionaries
Wallace took the education that his
uncle had begun and headed to Dundee to
finish it according to one story that's
where he killed the son of an English
constable who had insulted him it's also
believed he killed several English
soldiers after they confronted him for
stealing illegal fish and it wasn't
until 12 97 that it became something
more than a common miscreant and this is
where we're gonna take a moment for a
very important aside there are only a
few instances where a reliable source
recorded information about Wallace and
most of those have to do with his two
most famous battles full and
Stirling Bridge and spoiler alert his
execution aside from that sources are a
little iffy in fact the major source of
information on Wallace's life is a poet
named Henry the minstrel who was better
known as blind Harry he was born around
1440 and that means he wrote his epic
poem The Wallace a four century and a
half
after the death of real Wallace and
here's where things get even more
complicated blind Harry who was indeed
blind from birth claims he wrote his
epic based on the writings of a John
Blair Blair he said was a Benedictine
monk who had been close friends with
Wallace and who had written a biography
of him at the request of a senior bishop
there's no actual proof this request was
ever made even though it's technically
plausible to go one step further there's
no proof that a biography of Wallace
ever existed either but there is a
fascinating story that makes it possible
that manuscripts had actually been
written an early version of blind
Harry's Wallace poem included text by a
monk named Arnold Blair not John Blair
buried in another manuscript is a title
for that work supposedly written about
the Scottish hero along with a footnote
that read vide catonian MSS and that's
surprisingly important the catonian
manuscripts were given to the British
Museum in 1700 by Sir John cotton and
only 31 years later a fire destroyed
about a quarter of the manuscripts in
that collection was Wallace's biography
among them well we have no idea and that
means it's impossible to trace many of
the details of Wallace's life back
beyond blind Harry as if that isn't good
of using enough there are plenty of
details in blind Harry's definitive
Wallace work that historians have proved
to be false one of the very first a
sitations blind Harry makes is that
William Wallace was the son of Malcolm
Wallace he wasn't in 1297 Wallace wrote
a letter to the mayors of the German
towns of Lubeck and Hamburg the letter
has survived along with Wallace's own
personal seal it shows a hand drawing
back the string an arrow of a bow and it
includes a Latin inscription that
translates to William son of Allen
Wallace and that calls into question the
historical accuracy of one of the most
famous and oft repeated episodes in
Wallace's life the popularly told tale
is that Wallace had married a woman
named Marian and was visiting the lady
and their daughter when English soldiers
got wind of his location he ran and
rallied his own men but Marian was
executed in the meantime and this
cemented his determination to free
Scotland's from the English rule so did
it happen well maybe but also maybe not
[Music]
the English King didn't immediately step
in to take over the rule of Scotland and
instead he first tried to install a king
who he was fairly certain would obey him
without any questions that was John
Balliol and in all fairness it was the
Scottish Lords who asked and with the
first to choose a new ruler Balliol
seemed to fit the bill in that he was a
descendant of former Scottish King David
the first and the English crown also saw
him as something of a weak-willed
successor who would remember who put him
in power and be eternally grateful for
that
that was in 1290 and things went
sideways really quickly England and
France were embroiled in conflict and
Balliol not only refused to support
England but in 1295 he formed an
alliance with France that of course did
not go over very well at all the
following year Edward marched into
Scotland to throned Balliol and took
over ruling Scotland directly Scottish
Nobles were imprisoned or found
themselves for holding to their English
rulers and countless Scottish soldiers
were forced to march alongside the
English in their campaigns against the
French revolt came surprisingly fast and
even as Balliol struggled to
re-establish peace through more
conventional means the rebels believed
they had an advantage the English army
was fighting France too and statments
they had fewer troops to send against
the Scottish rebels in 1297 those
Scottish rebels kicked off the first war
of independence at lanark and sadly
exactly what happened is unclear even
lan arks official history makes it clear
that no one really knows just why Wallis
chose to gather his supporters at that
particular location but it is known that
Wallis killed the occupying sheriff of
lanark along with most of his men and
kicked off the rebellion in full this of
course is where the story about
Wallace's wife and her execution comes
into the tale but again some historians
believe they've outright debunked the
idea that she ever even existed over the
next month's Wallace and his rebels hit
targets in Dundee Antrim and scone other
uprisings were led by Andrew Marr Ian's
the MacDougall clan and on September the
11th 1297 things truly came to a head
across the river fourth at Stirling
Bridge the area presented some unique
challenges to advancing armies the most
famous of which was very real the
bottleneck that restricted the
advancement of the English army after a
series of failed negotiations for peace
the English army led by the
Earl of Surrey advanced across the river
to be northern sight Wallace was already
Kamsa there with his troops and at the
benefit of the high drowns he waited
until a large amounts of the English
cavalry had crossed the bridge to charge
with his spearmen pitting the cavalry
against the river and slaughtering them
wholesale only some of those that tried
to flee actually escaped the massacre
and it was a decisive battle that ended
with the unraveling of the Earl of
sorries coalition army where some
Scottish Lords had marched alongside him
including James Stewart's the high
Stuart that changed after Stirling
Stewart not only pulled his men out of
the English army but he attacked the
fleeing baggage train to encourage them
to leave just a little bit faster among
those the fleeing English army left
behind was Hugh decreasing him the
treasure of Scotland it's impossible to
describe just how much he was hated by
the Scottish rebels and his fate says it
all pressing him was flayed and some
sources say he was skinned while he was
still alive while others say he was dead
pieces of his skin were distributed
among the victorious as trophies and the
legend says further that Wallace took a
particularly large piece of skin and
turned it into a belt for his sword the
events of Stirling Bridge made that
Wallis was a hero sitting at the top of
a victorious Scottish army unfortunately
for Wallace it was a short-lived victory
now just before we get into the rest of
today's video make sure you protect
yourself while you're out there in the
scary world that is the internet if
you're borrowing things online you using
a public Wi-Fi spot you know think about
coffee shops maybe online shopping the
Christmas gifts or something like that
well you really should be using a VPN
and that's where Nord VPN comes in I
know it's tempting not to bother and
solidus hope for the best
but really those stories you read about
online about people having their data
stolen do happen and I don't want that
to be you whenever I'm browsing on
public Wi-Fi
I just keep nor VPN on all the time in
the background so I don't have to worry
about people stealing my data but it's
not just about security you can also use
it to change the country you appear to
be and so you can get video content or
other content that might only be
available in specific geographic
locations nor VPN is super fast so
watching videos through it no problem
there's no lag whatsoever they might
have heard about the Nord breach in the
news recently but it's important to
point out that no user information was
exposed because Nord VPN doesn't keep
any logs on its servers because it
doesn't keep any logs at all
however Nord VPN are still moving to a
100% own server model unlike most other
VPNs they are also improving other
aspects of their security
so stop protecting your Internet
experience today and get the Nord VPN
holiday deal at Nord VPN comm forward
slash buyer graphics or use the coupon
code by graphics you'll get a three year
plan for 81% off plus two amazing gifts
for extra months plus nord pass password
manager app worth a hundred and ninety
four dollars and 61 cents and let's get
back to the video
[Music]
after Wallace routed the English troops
sterling bridge he was honored at a
ceremony in Kharkov the forest Scottish
Nobles named him guardian of Scotland's
and this is one bits of the Wallis story
that historians know a lot about in 2016
the Scottish Borders Council and the
University of Dunnan conducted a
geophysics survey that uncovered the
ruins of the medieval Chapel where
Wallace would have been honored hundreds
of years ago unfortunately for the Scots
Wallace's triumph would quickly turn
sour Edward the first was a monarch not
about to stand for the humiliating
defeat his troops had suffered sterling
and in 1298 he marched on Scotland with
thousands of cavalry infantry and
archers arms with one of England's
greatest weapons the longbow and that's
ended up being Wallace's weakness
Stirling Bridge may have been a triumph
but this conflict far kirk was a brutal
defeat for Wallace and his rebels the
English monarch had learned from the
mistakes that the military made at
Stirling Bridge Wallace had favoured a
technique where he put his spin into a
series of groups called Schilt runs and
against cavalry it was a brilliant and
deadly strategy against long bows it
wasn't nearly as effective and for the
first time Edward the First's longbows
decimated an enemy those that didn't
fall to the raining arrows were sent
fleeing by charges from the English
cavalry and although both sides suffered
massive losses Wallace's lost something
else support Wallace retreated to
regroup and for the next few years he
disappeared from mainstream history the
hero who had not long ago sent letters
to the other leaders of Europe
proclaiming Scotland's independence from
England had escaped but he had also
resigned his position as guardian of
Scotland over the next few years he
travelled abroad and met with some of
those same leaders hoping to cement
allies for the Scottish course like the
sources for much of Wallace's life
sources that talk about his time abroad
also vary greatly in the details but
there are some fascinating tidbits to be
gleaned from them
[Music]
it's not a hundred percent clear just
where Wallace went first but it's likely
his first stop was Norway from there is
likely that he headed to France and a
strange thing reportedly happens Wallace
his trip to France happens at the same
time ed with the first was marrying his
second wife and that was Margaret sister
to Frances Philip the fourth the
marriage was by most accounts and
unconditionally happy one and when the
young Queen was widowed at just 26 years
old she swore to never remarry and she
didn't it also did what it was supposed
to do it brought the two longtime
enemies together just long enough that
England could turn her sights to putting
down rebellion in Scotland and according
to some sources Frances Philip the
fourth was on such friendly terms with
Edward the first that when Wallace turns
up at the French Court no doubt
expecting to find someone who hated the
English as much as he did
he was actually arrested Philip offered
to hand Wallace over to the English
crown but strangely he was just thanked
for the gesture and asked to keep polish
there why this was we don't know but if
there's anything history has taught us
it's that England's and France just
can't seem to stay on the same page for
very long within the year Wallace had
gotten back in the good graces of the
French King not only was he released but
historians believe they know he was
going next and that was to Rome to plead
his case for Scottish independence but
here's where things get slightly
complicated and it's also the perfect
example of just how little we really
know about Scotland's largest hero it's
going to take a little bit of
fast-forwarding to 2011 at the time
there was a letter sitting in the
National Archives in London and it was
said to be a safe conduct letter written
by Philip the 4th and addressed to the
Pope the letter confirmed Wallace's high
standing with the court of France and
asked the Pope to consider that when he
was deciding whether or not to hear
Wallace's case there were two theories
as to the provenance of the latter one
suggested that it had been taken from
Wallace when he was arrested by the
English forces in 1305 while another
suggested it had been carried by someone
else entirely and intercepted by spies
the letter was given to the national
records of Scotland under a long-term
loan agreements but there's a lot of
mystery surrounding it there's no
evidence to suggest Wallace ever made it
to Rome and when it comes to the
question of whether or not he was
carrying the letter when he was arrested
the closest expert
able to guess is just basically well
probably and that's kind of surprising
well this is this important
larger-than-life figure that represents
Scottish independence but when it comes
to concrete facts an artefact this just
not that much there
this letter along with the one we
mentioned earlier is it as far as Wallis
documents go they're being said we're
getting to the end of Wallace's tale and
it's not a happy ending
Tom account suggests that around 1303
Edward the first offered Wallace the
chance to surrender rinse pledged his
loyalty to the English crown several
times in fact
Wallace refused and even that is up for
historical debate the sources that claim
clemency was offered zuhr English so
it's unclear just what the truth is it's
not known exactly when he returned to
Scotland from traveling to Europe but we
do know he was showing up in skirmishes
across the countryside in 1303 after his
refusal to bend to the knee of England
and Edward the first Wallace was
officially declared a traitor to the
crown and an outlaw this declaration it
was a powerful one and it meant it was
open season on him
anyone could kill him without mercy or
feeling the least bit of guilt and on
the same note giving him aid or safe
passage was considered treason it wasn't
long before he was captured and handed
over to the English by a fellow Scotsman
named Sir John Menteith and this is
where we can say without a doubt that we
definitely know exactly what happened to
Wallace he was executed in London
Smithfield area on Monday the 23rd of
August 1305 we know because the events
the spectacle even was recorded by
numerous monastic chroniclers and for
the most part their testimony was the
same the execution itself was a long
gruesome affair but there was a method
to the madness the punishments rounded
out to fit the crimes that he had been
found guilty of and first was the crime
of treason as punishment horses dragged
him through the streets of London to the
site of his execution next was the
punishment for murder and robbery and
that was to be hangs until not quite
dead he was cut down and then suffered
his punishment for the desecration of
churches he was castrated and
disemboweled his organs set on fire in
front of him whether or not he was aware
of what was going on
sources are vague they do seem to agree
that when he was cut down from the
gallows he was still very much alive
lastly was the punishment for being
named and out more now
heading his head was mounted on London
Bridge and what was left of the rest of
his body was cut into four parts and
displayed in newcastle upon tyne
berwick-upon-tweed path and sterling
when we call the entire thing a
spectacle it really was his execution
marked the opening of the Bartholomew
Fair which was one of the largest
communal gatherings in 14th century
England there is a bit of irony at 2:00
and the Saint Bartholomew was both the
patron saint of butchers and of Tana's
was Edward the first making a statement
bringing an end to Wallace's rebellion
on the day dedicated to the patron saint
of butchers well maybe but it is of
course impossible to say for sure st.
Bartholomew's apocryphal literature as
him learning the secret cosmic knowledge
from the divine bringing together goats
leopards and even a werewolf in peace
Wallace reportedly skinned Hugh
decreasing him and wore his hide as a
belt long before he was beheaded by the
English King and Saint Bartholomew was
both skinned and beheaded before being
dismembered and having his remains
scattered to the four winds
much like Buffalo Mew became one of
Christendom's most tormented martyrs
Wallace became an even more important
figure for Scottish resistance after his
execution and remained so for hundreds
of years so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below also why
not subscribe hit the notification bell
and I'll see you next time
[Music]